good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the public
the imaginary ones
um welcome to this meeting of the
governance Nordic committee uh just a
couple of housekeeping uh fire
evacuation procedure the fire alarm is
it is activated vacate the offices via
the stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it is deemed safe to return the
chamber does anyone tend to film the
meeting
nope fabulous
um restriction on mobile phones with
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst meeting its progress please note
this meeting is being live stream for
members of the public the meeting will
also be recorded and will be
subsequently broadcast on the council's
YouTube channel
um are there any members who wish to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
I can't see any
um apologies for absence there have been
apologies received from councilor
Whitehead are there any other apologies
for absence
no Grand gender item two Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest
Fab this is going really well
let's keep going
um agenda writing three minutes of the
meeting held on 30th of November 2023 to
approve the minutes of the meeting held
on 30th November 2023 copy attached to
the agenda pack
um
please can I have a proposal and a
second although before I do that and
there was one action
um on the minutes of the last meeting
which I think was for Mr Webb about an
update for subject of cash collection at
this meeting
thank you chair we are currently
undertaking another audit of car parking
and enforcement and we should have that
finalized in time for the next meeting
of this committee which I think is in
July
okay
thank you Mr Webb
um any other questions or comments
raised on the minutes
fabulous please have a proposal and a
seconder
uh Professor councilor Garner seconded
by councilor shrub unless I hear any
objections I will take these as approved
a gender item for quarterly internal
audit update report
um Mr Simon Webb would you please
provide your update
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report summarizing the work
of the East Kent audit partnership on
your behalf since the last meeting of
this committee together with details of
our performance to the 31st of December
if I could draw your attention to the
table on page 15 that summarizes the six
new audits completed during this period
we were pleased to report substantial
Assurance in three of those areas those
being business rates discretionary
housing payments and also officer code
of conduct register of interests and
gifts and hospitality
we could concluded reasonable Assurance
in the area of a safeguarding
and a split Assurance in respect of dog
Ward and fly tipping and litter
enforcement
most areas were reasonable Assurance
apart from litter enforcement which
attracted a no Assurance
um audit conclusion primarily because
the council doesn't currently undertake
any letter enforcement activity
the final area was complaints monitoring
and unfortunately that also attracted a
no Assurance opinion the details of that
are given on page 22. I can say that the
council has more recently since the
closure of field work and finalization
of that report updated its complaints
and procedures and we hope by the time
we come back to do the follow-up in the
next couple of months that that should
at least be up to reasonable Assurance
the results obviously will be reported
back to a future meeting of this
committee hopefully the July meeting
follow-up is a very important part of
our work we don't just take Management's
word for it that they've implemented the
recommendations agreed at the time of
each audit we go back three to six
months later and check
um During the period under review We
undertook five follow-ups and they are
detailed in the table on bottom of page
of 20 through 23 uh into page 24.
um none of those areas were still
limited or no Assurance after follow-up
and the vast majority of the
recommendations had all been agreed and
fully implemented at the time of
follow-up which is very pleasing to see
page 26 of that reports
um that shows the progress against the
agreed 2223 internal audit plan to the
31st of December pleased to report that
as at 31st of December which obviously
is the three-quarter Mark through the
year we had achieved exactly 75 percent
of the agreed number of days
as at 28th of February last week we were
up to about 95 so we're well on target
to complete your plan we're very much
coming to the end of our work for this
year
um Annex 4 on page 31 shows the areas
which
um where well the areas where we have
concluded limited or no Assurance they
are still to be followed up and they
will be reported to Future meetings if
this committee for example complaints
monitoring is at the bottom of that
table and we will be following that up
as I just mentioned and Reporting back
hopefully in July
uh final appendix to uh this report is
the balance scorecard this is a balanced
scorecard of key performance indicators
for the East Kent audit partnership
itself probably the key one there is the
progress against plan which as I
mentioned is 75 as at 31st of December
uh cost per audit day we calculate once
a year and that will be in the annual
report that will come to this meeting in
July
um details of Staff qualified
satisfaction questionnaires returned Etc
are all detailed within that report as
key performance indicators
that concludes my presentation uh chair
but obviously happy to take any
questions on any of the items raised
thank you
members any questions or comments
Council Ghana
thank you and thank you thank you Mr Ed
for the report I mean in my
my disappointment
um is honed in on the
um
Dogwood and fly Richard fly tipping and
litter enforcement report I mean it is
very disappointing to that um we do not
have any littering in full I mean it
doesn't come as much of a surprise but
it's still disappointing that we don't
have any litter enforcement
um staff employed by the council and
that means that we are unable to fulfill
our promise to Residents and he's and
this is residence
who when questioned in surveys
put littering really quite high up the
priority and did you get any
any um feedback about how this I mean I
realized we're
a few weeks away from an election now so
that things will hopefully change after
the election and um we'll have a well I
won't make a part political point but
did you have any feedback on the reasons
for this and what might be being done to
make sure we do have littering
enforcement staff
thank you counselor um as members are
probably aware the council has
previously employed contractors uh to
undertake this activity
um it's not necessarily a terribly
um popular activity with certain members
of the public primarily those that drop
the litter
um that contract did come to an end
however and the council hasn't yet put
in place an alternative vehicle of
delivery be that in-house
um staff or an external contractor if we
compare it for example to the CEOs who
do car park enforcement we do struggle
to recruit to those types of roles we
can only have about five vacancies for
car park Enforcement Officers which is
about half of the establishment of car
parking enforcement or Personnel
primarily because it can be very
confrontational
and of course literary enforcement would
be similar so it is an area that the
council needs to consider how it is
going to deliver in the future but we
will probably need to be realistic about
our chances of recruiting to those types
of roles if you wanted to add anything
quiz or if members were happy with that
thank you Simon
um yes the summer said we did have a
contract in place uh with a chemical
Kingdom um they provided services to
other authorities
um it I don't think it was provided to
our satisfaction as I think
um
my knowledge of it that the fines were
that were issued in a number of cases
for what you would consider relatively
minor offenses people dropping cigarette
butts and the like which of course is
still littering but not perhaps focused
on some of the more serious
um concerns I'm sure our residents have
we are looking at what we can do in
terms of enforcement less enforcement
and the going forward in the future
um you'll be aware as part of the budget
we've put the coastal enforcement
officers in they'll be able to undertake
some of that activity
um during the peak season when they're
working on the coastal areas but also
during the quieter months when it's off
peak there'll obviously be less Coastal
sort of enforcement activity they'll be
doing and they'll be able to undertake
some of that litter enforcement activity
around the town areas during off-peak
season but we will obviously continue to
review this
um because this is a new new initiative
that we're putting in place to see how
successful or otherwise it is
foreign
employing finding people to do literally
enforcement and the other enforcement
roles as his state is is difficult
because
some of the confrontations they have
potentially but I mean this must be the
same
among other councils across East Kent
and across the rest of Kent and I'm I
would assume or hope that um other
councils may be have ways around this
and they are able to employ Enforcement
Officers so would it be worth us
engaging with some of those other
councils to learn from those that are
doing it successfully so as we can maybe
use some of the practices they use as we
can make a better success of it
chair for me we'll so we're a member of
the Kent Medway environment group so
we're constantly working trying to with
other councils and trying to learn from
best practice wherever possible
um I think just again touching on some
of the points around the difficulties of
enforcement it does differ to where
we're talking about car parking
enforcement it's easier to issue a
ticket for car parking you've got a
vehicle registration you can issue a
ticket there to the vehicle when you're
issuing dingwood litter or even graffiti
enforcements it is a much harder
activity to enforce to identify the
individuals responsible for it and to
you know to issue the the fines
appropriately but
um
we're hoping that the the initiative
would put in place we anticipate it will
be successful but it's this is a you
know the coastal enforcement offices
this is a new branch of enforcement
activity that we're putting in place the
primary office has a focus on the
coastal activities as we've sort of
discussed as part of the budget setting
process but
um sort of referred to earlier I
anticipate will be able to use them
flexibly throughout the the year for
these types of activities as well
uh councilor Austin can I just ask a
follow-up on that one because I know you
and I discussed during the budget
setting process about Market supplements
and so on are we expecting those Coastal
Enforcement Officers to be paid maybe a
little bit more than we would normally
uh be expecting for the job evaluation
that we've done allowing for the
difficulty or difficulties of the
recruitment yeah well we have um
allocated Market supplements for the
parking enforcement officers because
they've been difficult posts to recruit
to we've tried different approaches to
recruitment there as well zero our
contracts because some
um some individuals actually prefer that
as a mode a method of employment
particularly for those types of jobs
where they can be more seasonal in
nature and we are I'm not sure if it's
finished but I know we recently started
the recruitment process for the
Enforcement Officers whether in a market
supplement is applied to it will be
obviously dependent on how successful
that is obviously if we're able to
successfully recruit and retain those
staff in those we wouldn't need to offer
a supplement but if we struggle to
recruit sufficient staff and number on
caliber of employee that we want with
again at that point in time yes
any other questions or comments
councilor Austin
thanks I'm I'm a new and um very um Fly
by Night member of this committee so my
questions may be rather rather ignorant
there's a um a section about the um
uh right at the very bottom about the
responsive Insurance about corporate
leak investigation and births four and
five and under staff matter and
obviously I'm assuming that most of that
information is confidential but
um are you confident that those things
are progressing as they should Mr Webb
and that we will have
um some information on those in due
course because obviously they're I think
linked to the recommendations that we
had from the Independent monitoring
officer it's very important that we uh
that we fulfill all those requirements
thank you councilor uh yes all three of
those um responsive pieces of work have
progressed well
um and where appropriate have come
before this committee um at previous
meetings
um in terms of birth four or five that
is now at draft report stage um and is
the Pro in the progress of being
finalized and the results will come
forward to this committee uh later day
probably July
if I could come in Simon thank you
um so where we are
um Simon said rightly the report now is
in draft stage I've had sight of it
um what we are looking to do
um is get this in front of cabinet and
then to council during this actual
Council period of time so it should be
seen by members prior to election uh
before the election period we may be
into the pre-election period by the time
it reaches councils but we're minded we
want to try and get as close to as
possible concluding the recommendations
or at least presenting the progress
we've made against the recommendations
to council the route it will take is to
Capital and Council because although
it's a governance related matter the IMO
and the statute recommendations that
were made by Grant Fountain came to
council and they were approved by full
Council it's a rather than coming
through this committee it will make its
way to full Council after being
considered and noted by cabinet
any other questions or comments from
members
I've got one um not sure if it's
question or a comment
um on bullet point three of the scope
for improvement on page 16 it talks
about consideration of official training
um program routes for undertaking for
both personal and professional staff
development and I'm not sure if you can
expand
um Mr Webb or perhaps Chris could
um
as to how that works because are they
Civic staff or TDC staff because I
presume if they come under civica we
have quite little flexing the training
if that could just be a bit expanded
upon
this certainly does refer to civica
staff yes absolutely
but obviously they are providing the
service on behalf of the council at the
present time and therefore we would
expect them to implement the
recommendations that are made on the
Authority's behalf
the agreeing with what Simon said that I
think it's a very valid recommendation
um civica provider I think of a high
quality service to the council it's um
you would have seen members on this
committee the reports that come in front
of you they are almost always
substantial or with an element of
reasonable with it so they are providing
and I would say a high quality service
and that partly is reflected by the
quality of the staff that they've got I
would say and that's I think partly why
the recommendation comes from because
it's essential for us to retain some of
those key staff in there and that will
be for
um I've got a another role that I
undertake as well which is the head of
shared service I help effectively
oversee and manage the contract for the
three councils that are part of the
arrangement with civica for business
rates and council tax so as much as it
being a an action for civica to
implement it's really for a conversation
that I need to be having with the
counterparts at Civic to help them
trying to enable us to retain the the
staff they're providing such a a decent
service for us
cool with no other questions or comments
we move to the recommendations the
recommendations are that the report is
may be received by members uh any
changes to the degree 2022-23 internal
audit plan resulting from changes in
procedural risk detailed at 0.5.0 of
annex 1 of the attached report be
approved members consider we're
appropriate requesting an update from
the relevant directors to the next
meeting of the committee in respect of
any areas identified as still having
either a limited or no Assurance after
follow-up that members consider
registering their concerns with cabinet
in respect of any areas of the council's
corporate governance control framework
or risk management Arrangements in
respects of which they have ongoing
concerns after the completion of
internal audit follow-ups reviews and
update representations from the relevant
director please can I have a proposer
under seconder
proposed by councilor Lee's seconded by
councilor Dexter and it's a hearing
objection I will take this is approved
fabulous moving on to a gender item five
we go back to Mr Simon Webb for the
internal audit Charter and draft
internal audit plan 20 23-24
thank you chair we seem to be missing
the covering report for this agenda item
but we do have the three annexes which
are undoubtedly the most important
aspect of it
um I'll ask the committee Clark to
circulate the covering report to you via
email after this meeting and also ensure
that it's put on to the council's
website this report is for approval by
this committee so we're asking you to
approve the audit Charter for the next
three years and the 2324 internal audit
plan
um of the three annexes Annex a is the
internal audit mission statement which
is literally just a paragraph
Annex B is the internal audit Charter we
ask you to review this every three years
um to be honest nothing really has
changed in the last three years apart
from the addition of the glossary of
terms the charter sets out the what why
and how of what these can audit
partnership do for thanet District
Council and the other partners they've
been Dover uh folks in highs and
Canterbury councils we are governed by
internal audit standards the namely the
public sector internal audit standards
both Christine Parker and I are
chartered internal Auditors and are
bound by the ethics and standards
prescribed by those governing bodies
um so as I say the the charter sets out
what we do how we do it and why we do it
um basically back to First principles of
internal auditing
most importantly is annex C which sets
out our proposed program of work for
2324.
um members who have been on this
committee for some years will be
familiar with the format so the annex C
is on page 55 of the agenda pack we
um show the complete well what we call
the audit Universe which we consider to
be all auditable areas of the council's
businesses and we break them down
between Financial governance housing
systems ICT Human Resources Etc
for ease of reference we are showing
um the year that we last ordered each of
those activities what the Assurance
level was and where appropriate I've
given that Assurance level after
follow-up because of course it may have
gone up after follow-up
and the number of days that we're
proposing for 23 24 the quarter that
they're prioritized for we also show a
four-year strategic plan so we are
showing notional plans through to 26 27.
now in accordance with guidance from
both sipher and The Institute of
internal Auditors we're only asking you
to approve the 2324 plan this evening
because that guidance says you should
shouldn't agree a plan for more than 12
months
and indeed undoubtedly during the course
of the year the plan will vary slightly
there will be unplanned responsive work
such as the birth four five project that
we undertook in 2223 quite rightly the
internal audit plan moves with risk
uh we have regard to the council's risk
register when preparing the plan
um very high up on your risk register
which um you'll see as an agenda item
later this evening is ICT cyber security
a very topical issue at the moment it's
gained even more risk due to the Ukraine
conflict has quite a lot of cyber
attacks come out of the Russian
Federation
um you'll notice on page 58 that we have
a review of cyber security and we
prioritize that for quarter one of 2324
um
in putting together the plan I've met
with all heads of service and directors
to discuss the emerging risks and
opportunities within their service areas
we've also had as I've mentioned regard
to the risk register and also our own
internal audit and perception of risk
and internal audit experience of each
area of the council's business I mean we
have been undertaking
um internal audit forth and history
Council for the best part of the last 15
years as the Eastern Audi partnership
indeed I myself probably have been doing
it for about 30 years so we do have
quite a body of experience of auditing
in this Authority
um
So the plan is broken down between
Financial governance housing systems as
you would expect a fair bit of coverage
of housing stock
human resources which came back in house
very recently
um obviously
um staff are your primary asset and as
payroll is one of the most significant
areas of expenditure within the
organization we undertake a review of
payroll every year to ensure that we are
undertake adequate testing of salaries
expenses and benefits
corporate governance
um very important to the council it also
appears on the risk register so we break
that down into constituent parts and
audit certain areas each year
Performance Management an important area
of the council's business uh clearly we
want assurance that we're delivering on
the corporate plan objectives of the
organization and the best way of doing
that is through having
[Music]
um
well-tailored key performance indicators
to ensure that we're achieving as an
organization the outputs that our
residents require
uh we undertake a certain amount of uh
fraud work and propose to undertake some
data analytics in terms of data matching
um certain
bodies of data
procurement contract audits they will
feature each year and next year is no
exception to that with reviews of CSO
compliance
ICT I mentioned we've got three audits
planned one being the cyber security
um and then into the service areas of
the business so we're proposing audits
of things such as Community safety areas
of environmental health Grounds
Maintenance very high profile area at
the council's business
um
employee health safety and Welfare your
leisure Vics
quite a broad
coverage across all areas of the
business
the yellow highlighting indicates areas
which we aren't covering within a
four-year cycle within the charter we
express a desire to provide coverage of
all areas within a four-year cycle
that's not always possible so it tends
to be the lower risk items that tend to
drop out to that four-year cycle
with some areas particularly ICT housing
benefits payroll Etc being done much
more frequently in the case of payroll
annually
we also on page 62 have the eks civica
plan with ICT coming back in house from
the 1st of April the ICT audits have
come into the main Planet plan so that
leaves within the civica plan revenues
benefits debtors
and I think that's about it now within
that area
um the plan proposed is for approval if
members are so minded we hope to hit the
ground running on the 1st of April and
we'll be auditing from that date against
this plan if approved
that's it from me chair
um so if I could recommend the plan and
Charter two members for approval happy
to take any questions on any item within
the agenda thank you
any questions or comments from members
fap
um
so the recommendation is that the report
is received and approved by members
um can I get a proposer Charlie Lee's
and seconded by councilor shrub
and let's hear any objections I will
take this as approved
perfect moving swiftly onto a gender
item six
um quarter three review 2022 to 23
treasury management annual investment
strategy Mr Chris Swindell will you
introduce the report
certainly thank you chair so this is the
third quarter
reports for the committee to note and
make comments on in terms of our
treasury management activities so brief
reminder it's not about budgets and
expenditure it's more about how we're
managing our cash what our debt Holdings
are what we're doing with any spare
money that we've got
um in terms of investment or otherwise
headlines you can see in the executive
summary that I'll just bring out
um quite concerning I would say overall
is
um the the main item of concern is the
third quarter position so 75 through the
year you can see that we've only spent
10 and a half million pound against a 50
million pound budget for the capital
program
um so that's 20 spend when you're 75
through the year some of that would have
just been because the way the budgets
have been set up they were set up I
would say
um they were incorrectly phased when
they were first approved so a lot of the
um
the the budgets that were that were
approved in relation to some of our
regen scheme in reality we know they're
going to be spent over a longer period
of time but the budgets will have been
put solely into this financial year so
there's a profiling issue there in terms
of the way the money's been spent out
but undoubtedly there will be some
slippage there the detail of which will
come forward to members and cabinet as
part of the budget monitoring process
and that reports also goes to OSP for
their consideration
in terms of debt and Investments you can
see that position remains largely
unchanged it's around the 20 million
pound Mark we tend to borrow
um only when we absolutely have to we
use our internal resources rather than
going out to external organizations for
debt that remains our position and we're
holding less debt than our Capital
financing requirements so
in terms of actual money that we've got
from the bank we've got 20 million but
to order to finance all our Capital
plans there's 55 million so actually you
can see the majority of the money is bit
the financing of our Capital program is
coming from our own internal resources
rather than going out to the market to
get debt in terms I've talked about if
we've got any spare change to invest
we've just got the the slight master of
55 million pounds worth of balances in
our investment and you can see in the um
the appendix how that is broken down in
terms of the the types of Investments
that we use the large majority of it is
place in Money Market funds which are
Super liquid low risk Investments and
you can see later on in the report sorry
I've skipped around I've just lost where
I was
um
that are the average rate of return that
we're getting on those Investments is
1.74 so that's the average for the first
nine months of the year we obviously
know during this year interest rates
have gone up but over the average period
of the year uh we've got around 1.4 but
the actual rate we're getting on Armani
Mark money market funds now is closer to
the four percent you're getting in terms
of Base rate
the good news is in terms of this if you
see at 3.7 we budgeted at the start of
the year to get 167 000 pounds in in
terms of investment income because
interest rates were so low half a
percent we've actually got
um for the first nine months of the year
almost three quarters of a million pound
and we've factored that into the budget
for next year so you may remember when
we set the budget we put an extra half a
million pounds worth of investment
income into the budget
um because we're expecting interest
rates to go back down the property
peaked I would say now and our
expectation is they'll probably start to
taper back down depends how the economy
performs but we think that they're
they're unlikely to go much further than
they already are so that's a welcome
bonus for us in terms of the performance
on Treasury management and certainly
helps our overall financial position
uh that's largely all I've got to say on
the reports at um this uh at this moment
Thomas that it is for the committee to
to note but I'm happy to take any
questions that members may have
counselor
sorry rookie question
um Investments I noticed we've got um
two million pounds in a deposit fund
that's specifically marked as
sustainable what about the rest as I'm
thinking about I know there are councils
that have declared climate emergencies
that are looking very closely at where
they invest or they investing in fossil
fuels all that kind of thing I'll be
doing that kind of analysis at all
we um so we do look at it and consider
it one of the issues with treasury
management and what we've looked at this
at some depth it's the framework that we
have for treasury management puts
um the onus on us to primarily concern
um first the security of the investment
so we're not gonna you're not giving me
55 million to put it all on black down
at the local casino the local casino I'm
going to lose lose it all
um yeah that's that's definitely not
allowed to the center issue management
strategy that's not permitted
um second is liquidity so we can get the
money when we need it and third is a
yield so those are the primary concerns
we've got when we're looking at the the
sustainable Investments the two million
with God is actually very good
investment in terms of of return and
yield as well as it being having good um
ESG environmental social and governance
credentials
if we want to do something it's a little
bit more
um
exciting you're pushing the envelope so
to say in terms of
environmental or social credentials
you'd need to take it out of the
treasury management framework and put it
into the capital program and say we're
actually putting an investment in we
could you're perfectly we could do this
obviously I would provide advice on the
the worthiness of it
um points a note of warning
thorough Council pretty much all of
their money into solar farms and have
lost hundreds of millions of pounds for
it so you need to do due diligence you
need to make sure it's a solid
investment but we still can look at
options like that but it really needs to
be outside of this treasury management
framework because when we're doing that
it's all about how well are you looking
after your cash and environmental
concerns are cut a secondary to that
really it's it is a frustration but it
is it's part of the legislative
framework that we've got to work with
question so the treasury management
framework that we're working within is
the legislative framework we can't it's
not one that we've decided to adopt uh
yeah this is
rules that we have to comply with
um the external authors would look very
poorly honest some of it is set in
statutes and some of it is
um some of it's stuff you have to do and
some of it's statutory guidance that you
have to show and you've considered it
um but again if if we didn't pay
attention to statutory guidance it would
be in a lot of bother very quickly yeah
any other comments or questions
um Chris you just touched on there about
the external Auditors could you give a
quick update as to where we're at thank
you yes
um so those who've been on the committee
for some time uh Mike you've been
um I'd say a willing volunteer on the
final accounts close down group that
we've had we've unfortunately
um members be aware that the 21 22 final
accounts the draft accounts are still to
be published so we're almost a year out
there are some
um
mitigating factors and reasons why
there's been such delay
we had a very long-standing member of
Staff who left the authority in March of
last year who was effectively the key
member of Staff who led the accounts
closure process we still had some covert
restrictions around that time of as well
it's very difficult to recruit staff
particularly staff who are willing to
come into the office and work in person
the individual that we recruited the
consultant that worked with us was
remotely based and I think it's fair to
say they didn't do the job that they
promised they would do for us and
consequent we've had to recruit someone
else to undo a lot numerous mistakes
that were implemented we're nearing
completion of that now we're aiming to
publish draft accounts by the end of
this month or early into April mainly
because we need to get this done because
as of first of April the team will then
be working on closing the 22-23 accounts
so that's where we are in terms of
production of last year's draft accounts
we still have outstanding as well the
audit of the 2021 account that that has
been largely completed the Auditors
aren't here so I can partly blame them
has been due in part to resourcing
issues at both then the external
Auditors the in the manager that
managers our audit had taken a
sabbatical and effective we put a pin in
that audit he's actually written to me
today's return then we'll be getting
that shortly we've again we've got a
very similar time frame that we're
expecting to wrap that audit up and
publish final accounts for 2021 at the
end of this month or the beginning of
April so my plan is for the final 2021
account alongside the 2122 accounts have
been will have been audited and will
come to this Committee in July and at
the same time for us to present draft 20
to 23 accounts so there's a lot of
activity that will be going on within
the finance team over the next couple of
months
thanks no thanks
um Council Tony
for us for fire
I what and are there penalties involved
when we don't file our accounts I mean
how come we've got away with it for so
long and you know I mean it's ridiculous
that we have you know uh I mean normal
circumstances if I did twelve accounts
of my company I get fired my company's
house as simple as that I can be struck
off okay so why haven't we managed to
actually you know perform in accordance
to the sanctuary requirements so there
are statute requirements what I would
say they are toothless
um so uh apart from being named and
shamed and that's having to put a notice
on our website there are no implications
at all for us not publishing our
accounts I can say that we're not
uh we're not an isolated case we're
probably in the pack
um the number of authorities that have
not
um been able to get their audits
completed partly because of the issues
in the audit external audit markets at
the moment the there's significantly
limited capacity in terms of the
Auditors of available to do the work
it's
um I would say it stems back to the
abolition of the audit commission that's
happened around
2011-2012 prior to that we had the
district Auditors that oversaw it the
privatization of District audit
effectively has not worked it's not in
my view it's not a sustainable market so
they're looking at putting measures in
place to address the audits that of
course impacts on the 2021 where there's
been delays in the audit in terms of 21
22 yes that it's quite clear it's not
acceptable that our draft accounts are a
year late and I can only offer my
apologies for for the delay the reasons
for that as I've set out are because
there has been
um significant turnover and key staff
within the service within the financial
service area and there's also
local government accounts are incredibly
complex I mean you those who have seen
them will know they are hundreds of
pages long with numerous disclosures you
can't just get
um a standard accountant into come and
close your accounts is a very limited
pool of specialized accountants who work
and who are practitioners of local
government accounts unfortunately we
didn't get a very good one who came and
did our accounts for
2012. I'm the officer we've got working
on now again as an interim but she's
extremely competent extremely capable
she's been with us for a while now she
comes into the office three or four days
a week which I can say makes a huge
difference in terms of being able to
work with the team and as I said I'm
confident that we'll have those
published but that is still late and I
can make no
um there's no other sort of excuse to
say apart from we've had resourcing
issues but we're not alone there's a
number of accounts that across the um
across the local government sector
number of authorities haven't published
their accounts or haven't had their
accounts ordered to Jim
councilor Austin
Chris can I just ask are you confident
that your Finance team does actually
have the capacity now to do all those
things all at once I'm thinking about
all your additional responsibilities all
Matt's additional responsibilities Etc
have you really got enough bodies to to
get all that work done but certainly
Matt and I have been squeezed so you'll
be aware Matt's been acting Director of
Finance and operations which is a very
unique set of services to be grouped
together I don't think that's a role
you'll see anywhere else in the country
some are managing
um you know a procurement team and a
waste collection team at the same time
um
with the we're still probably a little
way away because we need to get the
corporate the corporate restriction has
been approved but we need to staff it so
we're probably looking at those interim
Arrangements being in place until June
but below myself and Matt I'm I am
um
I'm confident the quality of staff that
we've got in the moment we have got some
interims in to assist us
um and said it's going to be a very busy
period over the next few months and
we've got the ability to dip into that
interim Market it's a little bit better
than it was a year ago I think covert
had a significant impact on it on the
quality of staff that we could get hold
of and the working environment
closure of accounts really is the team
effort remote working is great if you're
working in isolation but when you need
officers working together as a team you
really need them and co-located
okay unless there's any other more
comments or questions I'll move on to
the recommendation that the governance
and audit committee notes and makes
comments on as are appropriate for this
report please can have a proposer
councilor towning can I have a seconder
councilor Dexter and it's a hear any
objection I will take this as approved
approved moving on to agenda item seven
procurement waivers for 2022-23 please
go and introduce Miss Gemma Paul to
introduce the report
I'll actually introduce this report if
that's okay German procurement manager
it's her first time at committee tonight
I believe so she's here in an
observational capacity but if you've got
any specific questions about the content
of the report Gemma is the expert in the
room on procurement and will be able to
answer them but I will obviously I'll
introduce the report please go she's
highly capable officer loads of stuff
but be gentle with her on her first
appearance at GNA tonight
um I was looking yeah looking straight
at the ETC just keep those questions to
me that's fine
um so this is the second time we've
bought this report so it's uh to
committee we brought about a year ago
going unfortunately haven't been able to
keep the momentum going partly for the
reasons we're just talking about
um in terms of the stretch on resources
and the finance team I think this is a
really useful report to bring to the
committee because it gives you an
indicator of instances where we've not
effectively followed up the rules that
are set out on our constitution we've
waived the rules we've taken a deviation
from those and in terms of our
procurement activity that's very
important because it's important that we
demonstrate we're getting value for
money and we are acting transparently in
terms of our Contracting activity with
our suppliers there are instances where
we need to move swiftly and be nimble
and not go for a thorough and full
procurement process and that's why we
have this framework for waving
procurement rules in place the report
sets out so again looking at the exact
summary just to re walk you through this
yes the first table sets up the
different limits and the rules that we
have to follow for contracts of certain
value
what I should set up this is the
contract value not the annual span so
some contracts will be spread over five
years so for example you could have a
contract that's fifty thousand pound
over five years that will fall into the
top top bracket and you've got to go
through a fully compliant procurement
process even though the annual spend is
lower
um if you then look at the the table
that's just at the bottom of the first
page in the uh executive summary you can
see the number of instances where we
have waived our procurement rules
um so far so it's up to the middle of
February so 39 instances uh we approved
that
um of that of those instances you can
see the breakdown of the different
departments and the value of those
contracts you can see the large majority
of them are a relatively low contract
values and there was only one instance
when a waiver was presented to us and we
said no you can't do this the contract
may have gone ahead but it would be
considered non-compliant so it's not
complied with our rules that does place
the council at some risk because we
could be subject to challenge by
supplier otherwise
that's that's the sort of the Crux of
the position where we are now the other
thing to to note is we are looking to
change the the rules that we've got in
place in terms of the contract values
you can see
um and that final paragraph and the
executive summary that we're going to be
moving that bottom limit from 10 000
pounds up to 25
000 pounds the reason for that it's it
will reduce some of the uh
Administration that officers have to
undertake for relatively low contract
values again we could be talking about a
five-year contract that's worth five
thousand pounds a year so not huge sums
of uh of money so that they they've just
got to be able to demonstrate they've
got bass Valley rather than going
through and get three written quotes and
the like the reason it's set at that 25
000 limit is there's some um Gemma will
be able to tell you more if you if you
want the particular detail and the
public contract regs we've got that
right 2015.
um we've got a post
um on our website at a cancer Midway
wide website all contracts that are of a
value of 25 000 pounds so that's why the
limits sort of tying together and we're
looking to make the change to the
Constitution to reflect that it's been
in the
um offering for a little while the
reason it's been delayed is we've been
waiting for the corporate management
team restructured to be
um finalized and we're almost there
happy to take any questions and as it
says in a recommendation
the report is for noting
that's for Austin
I'm sorry
um I'm noticing I can see why we've got
we've got some waivers because of you
know small value I can see when we've
not had um enough people come forward
etc etc we also seem to have an awful
lot of the extreme urgency and you and
this has been something we've been
concerned about I know some of us
members on other matters you know why
did we have to make an urgent decision
about buying bin wagons when we have to
buy bin wagons every so many years
anyway Etc how do how do we compare with
other Authorities on this and what are
we doing about it if we don't compare
well
uh I would say uh anecdotally on the
face that Gemma may have a different
View and Phil please feel free to
contradict uh me it's difficult to make
um like for like comparisons to other
authorities because we have different
Arrangements in place uh so for example
particularly the example you gave in
terms of um Ben Lowry's some authorities
have a completely contracted out waste
collection service so they wouldn't be
doing that type of activity I think it's
a very valid point in terms of urgency
and I would say that's the one we
probably pushed back most Gemini had a
conversation about one today where a
waiver was presented to us in terms of
being urgent
um in January wasn't it I think they
first engaged with you they went away
had another look at it and they come
back to us today saying please wave it
it's urgent we've said no because in the
space between January and now they could
have actually undertaken the compliant
procurement exercise so we do push back
hard on that I think it's been partly
possibly reflected of some of the
limited resources that we've had at C in
your management level I would expect
when we've got a fully staffed senior
management team for us to see a
reduction in the level of these urgent
waivers because we should have better
management
resources in place to manage these
prices Gemma I don't know if you want to
say a little bit more around the work
you and your team are doing to produce
the schedule of procurement that are
upcoming in order to try and help
officers know what is upcoming like
you're saying we we know we're buying
these Freighters they've got a life for
seven years it shouldn't be a surprise
in seven years that we've got to buy
some new ones but uh Gemma you wouldn't
mind saying a little bit more about that
certainly
um so what doing at the moment we're
going to produce what we refer to as an
internal contracts register so it's
basically like a tool for officers to
help manage them through the current
procurement process they're doing and
also through to when it's awarded and
what they have to put in place after
that and so it's a way of having them
all the documents in one location before
them and I have all the details of the
contract whether they received a waiver
for it and when the insurances are due
and they if you've got five-year
contract those insurances would be due
every year and it's the officer's
responsibility to make sure that's in
place as part of contract management
um so the idea is it will help officers
to program it in they have all of the
dates that they need to do which should
help get the next procurement on track
and so they're aware ahead of time and
to put these things in place it'll all
be in one place for them so they'll have
a long list of ways that they can can do
that and we're also doing refresher
training with officers across the
council and and more training on roles
and responsibility so they can
understand what's from our side and
what's from their side
thank you
councilor towning
I want to go back to uh the uh agency
staff
how do you actually deal with them when
it comes to contracts because the
fluctuation of different areas like you
know the beach clearly for example you
know uh or you're talking about the
dustman you know they there's a lot of
agency staff in there how what sort of
formal formal contracts do you actually
put together for these type of people
because the seasonal summer fit as well
so how do you work that out how do you
go about that
yeah I'll try to answer that I so we do
have a current framework agency
framework in place
um the idea is it was supposed to be for
across the council so including wasting
recycling operational Services all those
types of roles for
um but it would also include admin and
what we found with this contract is it
didn't cover
um all of the roles all the agency staff
that might be required across the whole
breadth of the council and it is coming
to an end shortly I understand that we
have extended for this final year and
because we can't find a framework that
would take place of the whole Council
and we're going to have to separate that
requirement out going forward so
operational Services would have a
contract for themselves which dedicated
to those specific roles and the rest of
what we would call more specialist
requirement or the basic Adeline things
would be done through potential
framework is what we're looking at at
the moment rather than an open tender
process and it's something that's been
looked at the moment to get in place for
that requirement but there is a current
contract in place
so just to say um Germany you could
probably describe this better but just
for the committee benefit when we're
talking about framework contracts yeah
so they are General
um contracts you can framework
Arrangements you can call off as and
when you don't have to go through a
fully competitive process it's already
got on to
absolutely you can just select them
through that
um yeah it's worth noting so
the arrangements Gemma talked about
around Op Services and administration
but if you're looking at other
professional staff they wouldn't
necessarily be on that uh those types of
contracts so again what we tend to do in
those instances get at least
three
businesses agencies recruitment agencies
involved in it if I'm looking for one of
Finance I'll talk to sip for Panna who
are the recruitment agents there I might
talk to Michael page or Reed or someone
else or other recruitment agencies are
available
to make sure we've got we've engaged
with them all given them an opportunity
and we've got at least typically three
quotes as well but even with that we
tend to have to waive our contract
standard standing orders because the
contracts have a high value if you if
you've got a senior member of Staff
that's with us for a length of time
that'll be a high value contract and we
haven't put out through a full tender
process so we've tried to be competitive
we tried to make sure we've got value
for money but we haven't strictly
complied with the
um the requirements for procurement
they're in our contract standing orders
anything else you wanted to say
to that Gemma
I think that covers that I'd just say
the um the actual framework that we have
in place for the agency is one that we
put in-house so we did our own um agency
framework and so the idea was that you
had um for certain requirements you sort
of had blocks of different roles and for
that first set of role um you would go
to who was considered the top ranked
bidder of that tender process at the
time and then you go to the second one
if they couldn't provide it and there's
the third one and for the what I would
call
um more basic roles where you've got the
admin role side of it the idea is that
you would go to each of those three
suppliers on the framework you give them
equal opportunity to provide a an agency
member staff and a quote for that and
then you get to pick it's almost like
what we refer to as a mini competition
and then we would put that in place
Council leads
yeah thank you um I think probably just
Allied to what councilor Austin was
saying
um
the example I was going to pull out was
that of the
um Winter Gardens on it the Winter
Garden security
um and I think the further up the report
it says that lack of planning is is not
a Justified issue for issuing a waiver
um so who you know in the example of the
Winds Gardens we had we we sort of knew
that was going to happen for six months
at least
who is the ultimate decision maker as to
whether or not
um
uh there is lack of planning or you know
who does that come down to ultimately
well that's me ultimately yeah it is so
Gemma will Gemma will advise but it's
it's I've
um
there's a number of officers that have
to sign off a waiver first it will be
the uh a corporate director there's only
a couple of us at the moment so uh Bob
Porter for example would would sign off
as a director saying this is something I
endorse Gemma would then review it as
the procurement manager say actually
this is valid or not and then I have to
give the final sign off so for example
the the conversation was talking about
earlier uh the examples of my earlier
the conversation Gemma and I had it will
be up between the two of us to say this
is not a valid reason for a waiver you
know you you might say we haven't got
enough time but we actually think there
was sufficient time for you to plan this
in and you can go ahead and do this but
it will not be compliant and we're not
waving It Off
so they still can do it I can't unless
it was something that was it's not
necessarily illegal it just puts us at
risk because another supplier for
instance uh that say hypothetically
we're going to go out for a large
security contract and we just awarded it
to someone another security supplier
could say uh why did you not engage with
us why did you not go through a
competitive process and could
effectively try and take us to court for
loss of earnings or loss of potential
profit
councilor Tony
do we have a forward compliance officer
who looks at all our contracts and and
looks at them actual performance like
taking for example what we've just come
up with you know because compliance is a
very important aspect of everything that
we do and if do we have one it would
depend on the contract and then what's
in we don't have a centralized resource
but it will be embedded within the
service so if you think about housing or
building for building for example
housing
um have a large number of compliance
officers within there will look at the
works they're done to our tenants
properties because that's really
important to make sure the safety and
the uh and the quality of that work is a
sufficient contract standard
um but it will be it will be more hit
and miss depending on the contract value
but not going to have high level
detailed compliance on an I.T contract
that's worth five thousand pound over a
couple of years but if Dan's got a
contract that he's with a supplier that
he knows is high value is business
critical he'll have someone in his team
that will be looking at that to make
sure the supplier was look I mean Dan I
know your team's going through a lot of
change but you used to have those
contract officers that would be holding
them to account so those those
compliance activities sit within the
service rather than within gemma's team
but it's not uniformly done across all
contracts because we have to take over
some a risk informed
decision as to whether it's worth doing
it because otherwise we could possibly
be spending more money
can you know undertaking compliance
activity on the contract and the
contracts worth itself
councilor Austin
just putting on This I Promise
um the the waivers which rely on which
which are as a result of people not
being able to meet our terms and
conditions
isn't this not exposes to risks what
what
under what circumstances might might
that happen and we'd be okay with it we
always get legal to review them
um it can be quite often again I'm
looking at downcroft and this happens
with it companies typically is one of
the areas we see a lot crafting that
they can be multinationals and they're
gonna they'll just say they're the
single player in time they go no these
are our terms and conditions you engage
with us on these terms and conditions
um Samira is properly or Jammer is
probably better qualified to say in
terms of the risk that it presents to us
when I'm looking at changes I must say
for me usually it's one of the Lesser
um significant reasons why I'd be
concerned around a waiver when I'm
looking at waivers I'm really concerned
about are we getting value for money are
we being transparent are we giving all
suppliers equal footing this is more
around if legal are happy with it I'm
usually happy and I defer to Legal that
we're not exposed
thank you just to confirm that legal
department 2 goes through every single
document and they go through with a very
fine tooth comb just to make sure that
we are compliant so everything that
Chris and the team does we go through it
we've got a couple of offices we are
sure to staff as I think across the
board but we do what we possibly can if
we don't have capacity there are
external resources that I normally go to
and then we make sure that we are
complying
any other questions
um
the recommendation is the committee
notes the report please can I have a
proposer and a second review
um proposal council is seconded by
councilor towning unless I hear any
objection I will take this as approved
fabulous
moving on to a gender item eight back to
Mr Chris bondale it's the corporate risk
management quarterly update thank you
chair and if I may I'm going to pass
this over to Amy who is our risk and
insurance officer uh who is the the sort
of the author of this report and has
done all the The Works about further
adee over to you Amy thank you Chris so
the report as you all know provides the
DNA committee with a course new view of
the corporate risks so what I've thought
to do today is or we're going to
highlight some of the risks that have
actually changed and also highlight the
risks on the annex that have actually
gone up and down we've got some exciting
changes to the risk register in the way
that we do it we've actually changed the
risk scoring mechanism
um and the reason for that was because
we were finding a lot of service risks
we're slipping into the corporate risk
register and so we wanted to eliminate
that properly
um so just a bit of a background really
most of you will know that the risk new
risk management strategy was actually
approved last July
um and consequently we've been in the
process now for some time of operating
under the new risk management strategy
what I was saying a moment ago about the
way we changed the scoring mechanism is
so that we can remain agile with the way
we manage our risks and the way that we
look at the corporate risks as well so
this isn't just a set process that we're
following every time we're asking our
officers our directors and our managers
to actually move with what we're doing
in the risk management in the risk
management Arena so substantial progress
has been made and some of you will
remember that we were only getting about
40 to 50 response rate this time last
year I'm happy to say that it's about 96
now so we're actually getting responses
from across the council so this is the
whole Council this isn't just one
section this is every single service you
know service across the council and
within those Services the managers are
actually asking their guys on the ground
to feed into the risk register so we're
actually getting some really good risks
come through and the best thing is that
we've actually had some risks drop off
and that's really as a result of the
proactive you know approach that
everyone's taking so as a council it's
now possible to report these corporate
risks to the committee in accordance to
the updated risk management strategy
this is most notably demonstrated now in
Annex one which we'll come to in a
minute and with the presentation of risk
now through the lens of current future
and emerging risks so rather than just
being a risk we're actually delineating
between where does the risk sit and that
actually really helps us to look at the
mitigations of the risk what can we do
to actually improve the risks as well so
what I wanted to do was really just talk
to you about the the actual
um Matrix that we've got now most of you
will be familiar with the Matrix at the
bottom of page 105 and that's the Matrix
that we've been using probably for some
years in fact I think I've seen this for
about 20 years in Risk Management it's
not really changed and that's right that
is how we score our risks at the moment
so as you can see you've got the
likelihood against the impact but what
we found was that the way that people
were scoring these risks was quite
subjective what what was the likelihood
so they're going okay it's a four but is
it actually a four where are we scoring
that again and the same with the impact
so what we've introduced this time is
this news mechanism so rather than just
saying okay what is your idea of how the
risk is going to be scored we're saying
it has to go against these two these two
tables they're quite simple the the
first one which is actually the
likelihood this is actually asking them
is there a more than percentage so
that's actually giving us a real good
idea of what is the actual likelihood
but probably the most impactful is the
impact one actually
um and what we're actually asking people
to do now is to score that particular
risk against the headings of reputation
strategic well-being Service delivery
finance and compliance we've then asked
the directors when they're scoring their
corporate risk is to give us what the
highest one was that then gives us an
idea and you'll see it further down the
report and I'll highlight it onto on two
that have actually moved where we're
coming from so what that's actually
doing is it's actually eliminating some
of the service risks off of the
corporate risk of course they're very
important but they don't look on the
corporate risk report because they're
not a corporate risk so I'm pleased to
report that we've had no new risks
corporate risk this time so if we go
down to
um page 107 we will see that all the
rest there remain the same in terms of
the amount of risk that we've got on
there there has been a couple of changes
and what I was hoping to do was just
draw out those two particular corporates
of course we can talk about any of the
other corporate risks as and where
um but what I was going to do is just
draw out those first two so we've got
the environmental act that has sadly
gone up
um and we've also got the Madison
building which has gone down now you'll
note when we go down to the corporate
risks that you can now see that we've
got the impact scored and the likelihood
scored we've also got whether it's
current future or emerging risk or
whether it sits in all three or two of
them because of course not always
sitting one category some of them can
actually straddle all of the categories
but the one thing that you'll notice now
differently on the report this time from
the last time was they were actually
detailing whether it was reputation
Service delivery and so on which was the
highest score in Risk mechanism so if we
go down first of all to the
environmental act we do know that that's
gone up and the reason that's gone up
actually is is as far as I can surmise
is the timing of this so the
environmental act now which is our
current future and emerging risk and I'm
sure this is a risk that's going to be
very very dear to a lot of council's
hearts at the moment as well you can see
from this we've got reputation Service
delivery strategic and Financial Risk
score of four so that's that's actually
increased
um so that's actually why we've now got
a 16 on there but you can see that this
is really delineating against what the
actual risk is and where it sits within
this Matrix if we go down to the manston
road Depot buildings that's actually
gone down which is great news um that
was a 16 before the reason for that is
because we're actually having work is
underway to implement the required
improvements and mitigate the risks
moving forward so that's a really good
step in the right direction
obviously all the other the other
corporate risks remain the same and
obviously be happy to take questions and
I'm them afterwards but what I would
like to now point out is now the annex
so some of you might be familiar with
the annex some of you maybe not so much
so the annex really really brought in
um by ourselves
um in this last year to not just
highlight the corporate risk but also to
highlight the risks that's it just under
there because they're just as important
sometimes they're corporate risk but
they're sitting just under there
um I'm happy to report that there's no
new risks to the annex which is really
great news
um and we've actually had a couple
drop-offs so I'll just highlight the two
that dropped off because that's really
really heartening to see that this is
actually working and the risk process is
working so Jackie Baker's um the old
workshop with Jacob Bakers we are to
remove this risk as you can see from the
notes there and the site's been secured
and so on so forth there's notice has
been demonish has been placed there has
been a small delay due to asbestos
um but again this has been notified to
the HSE and work remains going forward
so this will now drop off of the annex
and the second one that has going to be
drop dropping off is and I think we
discussed this one actually at one of
the Committees a couple of um last year
which was the only some inappropriate
inappropriate Awards craft use such as
jet skis I'm pretty sure we did can
actually um
um discuss this so the reason this is
now dropping off of the annex is because
we've got five Coastal enforcement
offices due to be employed in 2023
um so obviously as these go along what
we do is every time we look at the risk
again see if it's been updated and this
is how we're going to report it
um you will note that everything else
Remains the Same on there as well and
that is that is it you can also see from
the annex the other thing I would like
to point out on the annex as well is
that we've actually delineated between
the current future and emerging and so
that's really quite helpful for you to
understand where that risk sits with the
council so what we'd like to do going
forwards is is we would like to look at
some risk tracking this is quite in this
infancy so what we'd like to be able to
demonstrate to the committee in the
future is the Pro aggress of the risk
without just being me reasoning out
exactly what's happened with them so
we've been investigating various
different ideas pie charts graphs Etc we
need a bit more data to be able to put
on there obviously before we can start
producing that
um so that's briefly the um the annex
and the risk register for this for sorry
the risk report for this particular
course
I'm happy for any questions
yeah thank you very much
um we've got two questions if that's all
right um one is about the the report
itself I'm sure when I had a look
earlier there was
um
there was something in the report that
mentioned uh Dreamland of faith and
strangers in particular
and uh there being a lack of budget to
facilitate compliance officer
I've just done look now and it's gone so
I don't know if there can be any
clarification other than that it looked
a bit odd when I saw it the first time
but
that's a an old version of the annex
that shouldn't have been published the
reasons for this
um pretty much as Amy was saying there
were some risks on there that officers
had highlighted
um for Management's attention but they
weren't really corporate risks they were
service related risks so for example I
think there's some detail in there
around the budgetary implications and
we're looking at like less than ten
thousand pounds so we'll spend that
money to address it as effective if if
it's not in their budget they'll have to
overspend to sort it out
so again looking at that table the
lowest scoring risk of one is less than
50 000 pounds so unless it's a problem a
financial problem or or it's a big
reputational issue always because sudden
it's going to be in like the the local
press it's not going to become a
corporate issue it's a service issue and
it's something they need to sort out but
it shouldn't have been on that report
and that's part of what Amy was doing to
push back on those offices to those
officers and unfortunately and all
version of that Annex that was
considered by management was published
yeah no the only reason it stood out is
because it looked it looked a lot a lot
different to bed through everything else
yeah
um the other thing is
um just about Cyber attack and I've got
a question
excuse me
uh there's a sentence that reads uh
unfortunately the Cyber Market is now
not conducive to our risk profile what
does that mean please
yes
um so I've worked in insurance for many
years and I've worked in Risk Management
sometime now and I've seen the changes
to the Cyber Market
um
the issue with the Cyber Market is it's
gone into what's called A Hard cycle and
Dan can probably agree to that so
whereas it used to be a buyer's market
it's now a seller's market the the
restrictions and the contingencies that
the insurers expect us to have in order
just to get a basic level of cyber
insurance is prohibitive it's stupidly
expensive and I choose the inspiration
it's probably not worth the paper it's
written on at the moment the Cyber
Market is is not in a good place so
really we need to be looking at at the
risk our sales we need to be looking at
how do we mitigate that risk how do we
self-insure ourselves there's a there's
a lot of talk at the moment around cyber
risk engineering as opposed to cyber
insurance so it's actually getting your
company to the right position and Dan
can probably provide a lot more detail
on that but again your your company
organization to the right position that
they've mitigated and limited those
risks
um so that's what it's meant by the the
right now cyber Insurance might not be
the way forward words for most local
authorities and most private companies
thanks Amy I was just going to add
before we go into the detail on side but
we have got
um done to give us an update about some
um private session of the committee so
rather than going into any detail in
terms of how we're addressing security
risks but very good question around the
insurance market so thank you
Council Garner
thank you yeah I'd just like to ask
about a couple of the risks in the annex
related to the um upcoming election and
voter ID
um you you've highlighted the risk of
not being able to find experienced staff
to work at the polling stations where
we're not very far off now
so um
I mean I was gonna say Obviously the
staff who work in the polling stations
are going to have a lot more to do this
time there's going to be a lot more
responsibility
and there's going to be um they're going
to need more training so at this stage
of the process could it might may be the
same more Chris really but for an update
on where we are with this are there in
what how concerned are we
um that we're not going to be ready if
we are concerned about it or how ready
are we going to be thank you
um we are we are we are concerned about
it and it's a fair comment I think some
staff have some hesitation or reticence
around the actual additional work
that'll be involved and possible
conflict they may be subject to because
of the voter ID it's new people don't
know what's
um what they're going to be coming up
against we've largely we've got a
um
we're getting there in terms of the
number of presiding officers that we
need at the polling stations uh I
managed to coerce and convince Dan to be
one earlier this week so we've got a
couple more that we need to find a
little bit of gentle arm twisting
um but yep it's necessary for us to find
as many as possible if not we will
obviously need to look externally that's
that's an option for us to recruit
external staff you don't need to be a
counselor staff to um to work on the
elections
um but it's the the elections are hugely
important for us
um any election is obviously a very
important exercise particularly when
you're dealing with District elections
it's the first time that councilors some
new councilors may come into contact
with Council officers so we need to show
that we can run an election if you think
we can run a council but otherwise it
doesn't create a very good first
impression so we are fully engaged with
it and with um you know we're getting
um we're pulling out all the stops
just ask a follow-up on that are we
including in those
the processes here we're going to keep
in track of
um voters who aren't able to vote
because they have the inappropriate ID
so it's at the end of the election we'll
be able to show how many people haven't
been able to vote and the reasons why
they haven't been able to vote I don't
know the answer to that but I will um
I'll speak to the elections team and and
ensure you get a written response
councilor Austin
wanted to pick up on an item in the
annex not in terms of our process or
whatever but in terms of the idea of
removing it which is the business about
the jet skis which is causing I mean the
the um
officer decision has been published and
has caused immediate great concern in
the community the only place that we are
now allowing jet skis to launch from is
a shallow public beach with no other
forms of protection or separation
between the jet skis and swimmers it's
it's used by young families it's a real
worry and we haven't as yet as local
councils it's somewhere very close to
where I live it's where I swim myself
we haven't had any information as yet
about what we're planning on doing
practically to mitigate the risks
um to to beach users so um I'm a bit
worried about that not appearing on the
schedule somewhere because I think
perhaps it needs to be monitored
obviously we know we're going to have
new offices but they're not going to be
there all the time we need actual
physical barriers of some kind some
means of making sure that people are
safe so in terms of that not being on
the schedule so this was compiled and
completed prior to that decision notice
being produced Amy as part of her work
will be working closely with the coastal
team so yeah Lisa and Mike cumber again
I don't I'm afraid I don't have the
specifics the hand of how we're going to
manage the risks associated with that
decision
um it's probably best to direct that
through to Lisa Luke and Mike yeah
it will be picked up as part of the
regular cycle
thank you
um thank you for your report Amy there
was just one part on it and it's only
noticeable because it's in red
um but the date says updated 30th of
March
I was hoping no one's going to notice
that and I couldn't get around to change
it I noticed it about half an hour
before the meeting so I will amend that
but it should have said January so we're
not in the future yet so apologies to
members on that one I will amend that
okay
thank you
um where are we
um so the recommendation is to approve
the review of corporate risks and
discuss discuss and its risks and please
don't have a proposal and a second to
approve the review proposed by councilor
Duckworth
unless there's any I hear only objection
I'll take this as approved
cool moving on to a general item nine uh
Holmes England audit new build now I
have Mr Bob pilter here to introduce a
report so unless he's um I don't think
he's hiding
um I can introduce this I did have a
chat with Bob about it in advance
um it's it's fairly straightforward uh
it's it's relatively I'd say good news
we have to
um we have to engage with with Holmes
England in terms of the funding they
provide us and it's subjects the schemes
are subject to audits to Grant Thornton
have done as you can see in the report
completely clean audit so we're just
presenting in this to the committee in
terms of full disclosure that it's had a
satisfactory and fully full and clear
audit so lots of green lights and green
text on this one
any comments
no brilliant so the Committees are suit
note the final grade Award of green no
breaches identified please can I have a
proposer and a seconder
proposed by councilor shrub and seconded
by councilor towning unless I hear any
objection I always take this as approved
uh move on to a gender item 10 which is
the exclusion of public and press the
recommendation that the public and press
be excluded from the meeting for a
gender item 11 as it contains exempt
information as defined in paragraph 7 of
schedule 12a part 1 of The Local
Government Act 1972. paragraph 7 any
action taken ought to be taken in
connection with the prevention
investigation of prosecution of crime
please kind of a proposal under second a
proposed by councilor shrub seconded by
councilor Lee's unless I hear any
objection I will take this is approved
sad and we will take a slight pause just
so we can stop the recording and
evacuate any imaginary